i'll take five suggestions i'll divide
you up someone gets a fair go let's come
to
this wedge first what would you like to
hear a rap about
world peace do you have any particular
insight is how we can achieve world
peace what do you think is the path to
world peace
i know this has probably had think tanks
all over them put women in charge
wonderful stuff um that's a
i mean yeah you have a formidable group
of backers over there they're like
yeah women cool putting women in charge
women in charge
leading to world peace i like that if
you are on this side of the room over
here what would you like a rapper
home oh i heard homeschooling and what
did you say
pole vaulting and homeschooling okay
home
homeschooling someone in the poll vault
that sounds
good so women being leaders and leading
to world peace
home school pole vaulting let's come to
the the very back of the room if you're
in the back watch your rapper
i i think i think i heard black history
month is that correct yeah
yeah represent that's the that's what we
do
so world peace being as a result of
women being in charge home school pole
vaulting black history month
let's come to the the middle of the room
if you are on this section of it what do
you want to wrap up
dodgers i've done i've done a recent rap
about the dodgers i'm afraid like i said
don't do the same
the oscars oh is there a moment from the
oscars you want us to focus on
parasite oh parasite winning the winning
the i mean four
four awards i think yeah it's a it's a
bomb movie it's pretty great
um done if you saw that trump spoke
about it in his rally today
um uh yeah he was not a fan of it um
let's come to you guys over here you
guys haven't had a go yet
what okay you have to be more specific
harry potter gets suggested a lot it's
very general
so what what would you like us to focus
on
on his wand
[Applause]
you've really tickled some filthy minded
individuals here
okay those are your suggestions then
these are what you've come up with so on
your own heads be it the suggestions to
remind you
world peace is a result of women being
in charge black history month
um pole vaulting homeschooling harry
potter's wand
and parasite at the oscars this then
lovely people of the comedy magic club
it's going to be a freestyle rap as i
said a wrap made up on the spot base and
telling those suggestions
it's never been seen before it'll never
be seen again and do not worry it'll not
be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe-curlingly bad
as you are expecting a privately
educated middle-class white boy to be
you seem very convinced let's let's drop
that beat good sir and show them how we
do
and you can pump it up a little bit as
[Music]
well
in my chair on oscar night i was fingers
crossing hoping that parasite might win
i love that flick so much i'm like whoa
boom jew take it off the hook i wanna
see all of the films kind of either
making it in up just no piercer if you
haven't seen his philmatic awe for her i
should have said cinematic should take
care when i saw him up there claiming
the gong
i was like i hope they haven't got this
wrong like la la land
and moon right they read the envelope
wrong not right but now they were
correctly speaking
saying all this film it's reaching a
whole new audience out of here but one
thing don't mix up with north korea
because their films
are so different they got kim jong-un it
doesn't make sense
if you see them on the silver screen
there why do all of the actors have the
same hair
why it's a dictatorial edict doesn't
matter though yeah glad we picked
this film first foreign language let me
say to the lady make a sandwich and just
say no
i ruled the world because the uk us run
by
girls everybody now we are in charge
we're gonna get world peace yeah we're
having it large
much better than the guys when they
start the war and now we're coming over
here
in rows of four gonna make sure the
whole world heals doing it while we're
wearing nice high heels stilettos baby
jimmy choos
all the amazing peace movements you do
you could say now we don't need you men
gonna take my ladies to the u.n
walk in and there you go toast high with
a glass of gregio
p no obviously have a good time everyone
settles down when you share a bottle of
wine
russia and usa they come together and
they're like oh we should play
in a nice way not more cold wars they
get so drunk they're rolling on the
floor like my mom does
with all the best friends february what
all the best trends
having lots of fun on every front we go
power black history month gotta
remember every little thing dr martin
luther king
jr malcolm x representing rosa parks
wouldn't move when she was sent to the
back of the bus she's like nah that's
not right gonna stand up gonna have
civil rights
gonna move on yeah no apology peace out
do that [ __ ] in montgomery
i'm gonna go over here and i hope i
teach a little child to
pole vault running up there but i'm not
really able to teach him so i just get a
big table i put it i don't have the
equipment he jumps up i'm like oh whoa
we went from the floor
up there it would be easier if you had a
coach to take the four meters usually
that is the record if he had a pole i'd
be more sure but sadly
he's over here on my team because i
would never give him those vaccines
that's why kids get homeschooled they go
oh no it's not cool but don't worry it's
really on trend
in the olympics you'll have some friends
all of the us team over here one spotty
little kid
growing no beard saying i was taught by
my mum pole vaulting is really fun
have a little jump let me get so high
sadly he breaks his neck and then dies
oh really sad don't get it a lot should
have stuck to the high jump maybe the
fostering flop
if you teach him at home you're getting
it wrong i like to teach harry potter
about the content of his wong
what was in there you know they talk it
was a feather from phoenix forks
shared that stuff with voldemort
professor mcgonagall
should have taught him that when the
ones clash in the fight they would set
that whole forest up with light because
that stopped him getting killed in the
jewel
never thought i'd have this much
knowledge not cool but i read these
books
a whole damn lot all of the harry potter
knowledge not forgot
i keep it in my brain and i spout it out
my favorite teacher was professor sprout
but there we go we're gonna try and sort
it out like the sorting hat
when it's there or about